we've done EU real imaginary parts I
want to use this modulus thing okay so
let's just take that line right I'll
meet this matched mod Z equals mod W now
I know a whole lot about set Adhamiya
right in fact I know even more than I
did when I first wrote them right I know
that mod Z is going to be mod cos theta
plus I sine theta and I now also know
that mod W is well don't know anything
cos out for yet I will soon I don't have
to write over here plus I sine alpha do
I
I know more about I sine alpha now I'm
going to replace it with negative a
minus I sine theta do you agree with
that okay now if you know where a
complex number is if you know it's
coordinates how do you find the modulus
to that point I'll give you yeah I got
it right I'm gonna need to take the
square root it's all hypotenuse of
something right so what are the two
shorter slides if this is this C right
what are the aim be in this triangle if
I have the quantity cos theta plus I
sine theta you know this is the
horizontal length of the triangle and
this is the vertical like that right do
you agree okay so actually the square
root underneath here is gonna be a
squared plus B squared you with me okay
it's just that my a happens to because
they up and I B happens to be side B no
I mean we could swap this wouldn't
matter okay all right what about this
side
swear it the x-value
there's the horizontal day that's how
far away I have to go so I've got cos
squared our [ __ ] where's this gonna go
now this is um this is going down isn't
it
do you agree with that that is what gets
squared but since its squared it's got
to become a length isn't it so it
actually doesn't matter that negative
side ends up being not consequential
okay our wheels turning yet I can do
something with this right I want to get
it water inside out of this first e
square everything that leaves me with
this I'm going to evaluate that's that
based brackets around here so that
leaves me with this and now what would
you like me to do one now what
hmm okay now I want to write the line
before the line Ethan suggested right
this is just getting rid of the sign
squids
okay we know we can we've worked as a
very painful lesson right the even
though cos theta equals cos alpha is a
solution to this it's not the only one
right there's another one if you take
the cos square alpha over the other side
you've got difference of squares you can
factorize right and you're gonna get
these two as your solutions do you agree
with that
those two be a solutions hmm now we know
which one we want to be the solution
right which one do we want we want them
both to be the same right
so therefore in some way you'd have to
deal with this guy right and by the way
like I've seen many students that I've
marked my solutions of students before
where they like ah I don't want the
negative one oh just get rid of it I
won't write it okay this is Mark there's
a mark specifically on that negative
sign and you resolving it right you have
to show that you know it's there and
then tell me why I can get rid of it
because we can any ideas
ah I can't hold on a second did you
catch that did you catch that maybe you
need to rewind a little bit right do you
remember earlier one we wrote because we
consider the real parts of it so we
write this doing that and we were like
well true but so what right we didn't
know what to do with that okay but now I
do know what to do with it okay have a
look at this consider what the two
solutions are consider what they are
right let's consider if the negative
case is true if cos theta equals sorry
negative cos alpha well what would that
mean that would mean if you add closed
alpha to both sides that would be in the
COS theta plus cos alpha is equal to
zero but but it can't be it could be
right because I concluded before was
negative one so this cannot be true
right did you see that I mean I guess I
would say if I was not so lazy I would
say it's a contradiction because I know
plus theta plus cos alpha is equal to a
different value to that so therefore
this can't be can't be the case that
something turns therefore the only
alternative I have is the positive 1 so
therefore cos theta equals the positive
one only does that make sense
ok now I'm pretty much there remember I
kind of ran into this brick wall well I
don't have a recall anymore because I
can say just like I did every heave this
relationship is cos theta plus cos theta
again because I just found out they're
the same is equal to negative 1 ok what
would you like me to do with that
- christina is is negative one I saw
what your brain was going your brain was
going to this light which is negative a
lot okay now I know what the domain of
theta is okay so where is cos T they're
going to be negative 1/2 here we go
here's the whoops negative PI - hi oh
yeah that so that's okay right negative
PI to PI at which two points because
remember I've got two numbers at which
two points is cos theta this is the
closed graph equal to there's negative
one we're just thinking of a half it's
gonna be here and if you do you agree
and I think if you check your numbers
you should find that song hundred and
twenty degrees because that's ninety
right which I'm wearing radians and
write or draw that as two times very
very good right now I've written both
because if theta is two pound three that
means alpha is negative two point three
or they just swap it doesn't matter
which ones which okay can we answer the
question how we're so very close we've
done all the hard part okay we've done
the hard part so what I can say is
therefore Z is equal to alright let's
just designate it one of them let's just
call that the positive one that makes
this the negative one
whoops they should yes sorry oh yeah oh
yeah so I've got my positive one my
negative one and then I'd say W sorry
one is where it is and then I'd
literally just draw that I destroy it
doesn't have to be huge or beautiful but
you can see the equilateral triangle
badness you don't have to labor at that
point you're done yeah I would I would
draw that diagram I draw that diagram I
place these two two points alongside 1
right and your heart okay